in this video we'll be talking about
autism spectrum disorders this is going
to be an overview in subsequent video we
are going to talk about this disease in
details so autism spectrum disorder is a
neurodevelopmental disorder that affects
the ability for social interaction
communication and the social behavior so
overall it's a neurodevelopmental
disorder now autism results in range of
phenotype and that is why it is known as
Spectrum so in one side of the autism
spectrum there is high intelligence
autism spectrum so these children have
different kind of IQs they have very
high uh degree of interest in one
particular topic or subject and they're
highly good at it in the middle Spectrum
there is average intelligence where
people struggle to thrive and struggle
to do problem solving or they find it
hard to interact socially and another
spectrum is low intelligence which who
who find find it difficult to perform
day-to-day task interact with people or
make new friends so that is why autism
spectrum disorder is a very broad
category of uh behavioral
Spectrum so there are different kind of
behavior typical ones are avoidance of
social interaction avoidance of I
contact especially unresponsive ESS
towards any kind of interaction let's
say the child is totally ignorant about
the interaction with the parents or they
refuse to hug or interact with their
parents hyperactivity is sometime a
prevalent cue they could be intolerant
to certain sounds or high sounds they
could be very sensitive towards it they
might have agitated mood sometimes other
side of the spectrum shows highly
depressed behaviors sleep Related
Disorders repeti ative behavior is very
typical and in extreme cases there could
be also epilep epilepsy associated with
autism spectrum disorder now each of
these phenotypes or uh symptoms that we
discussed right now cannot
individually suggest that a child might
be affected with autism so there are
different criterias based on which
autism spectrum disorders are defined so
there is a criteria known as dsm5 manual
which talks about
the uh specific criterias of Autism
Spectrum Disorder so this diagnostic
manual says that there is a persistent
deficit in social communication and
social interaction across multiple
context that means there could be a
deficit in Social
reciprocity simply saying that there are
abnormal uh way of communicating with
the world so basically let's say a child
is playing all by herself or himself and
not interacting with the friends let's
say when basically a child finds
something new they always want to show
it to other friends or their uh family
but in this case they show any lack of
interest to initiate a back and forth
conversation so this kind of failure of
back and forth conversation is one of
the Hallmarks of social deficit in
Social reciprocity so and these autistic
child do not want to share any of the
tools or any of the toys that they found
interesting so they have a lack of
sharing interest which is not really
true for a normal child okay there are
also nonverbal communicative
behaviors which are used for social
interaction generally a child would try
to communicate with their parents or
friend in a verbal manner even if the SE
sentence is fragmented still still they
would try to uh communicate in a verbal
fashion but in autism spectrum it has
been seen that sign languages are often
used to communicate also one of the
biggest uh thing about communication is
maintaining an eye contact in autism it
has been seen that eye contact is kind
generally
avoided and there is also deficit in
developing maintaining and understanding
relationships that means okay this child
doesn't have a healthy relationship with
parents or even a friends even if they
try to uh play with their friends they
often hurt or agitate the other friends
so maintaining relationship or
initiating relationship is also a
difficulty with this kind of condition
so all these thing falls under a um
umbrella term of social communication
deficit now there is also restricted
repetitive patterns of behavior interest
and activities this is another peculiar
feature about autism so there are
stereotyped repetitive motor movements
or some sort of like repetitive uh
Speech terms can also be associated with
autism for example a child is spinning a
toy repeatedly without any uh reason and
this is happening very fruitfully and
reliably all the time that child is
playing with that specific toy or let's
say a child really like to move their
hand in a certain way and they are kind
of like sticking to that behavior
pattern all the time some child like to
spin and spin and this kind of
repetitive patterns are very much
associated with
autism now it's also true that
inflexible adherence to routine or
ritually stic pattern of a particular
behavior is very typical to Au autistic
child simply telling that a child like
to play a drum and that particular child
would play the drum in a specific time
of the day in a specific corner of a
room so this kind of repetitive Behavior
would be done once and followed
meticulously all the time so this kind
of thing is very typical to autistic
child and also they they are highly
restricted um and they have fixed their
interest on a different type of uh
particular object they don't like to
explore many things but they have their
interest fixed towards a particular
thing so overall they perceive the world
in a different way compared to a normal
child so sometimes they show hyper or
hypoactive sensory uh outcome I mean
sensory uh outcome so basically they
might be agitated with a certain kind of
sound certain kind of color or Texture
so these are all very typical to autism
so already you can understand there are
different different type of phenotypes
which are associated with autism now in
our human brain there are specific
neurons in the cortex which fires in a
specific pattern so neuronal circuitry
operates in an asynchronous way and this
pattern way of firing is really
important for encoding memory and this
is possible because in the circuitry
there are inhibitory neurons and
excitatory neurons always there is a
balance between inhibitory and
excitatory
neurons and this balance maintains a
baseline firing activity in the neuronal
circuit two low or too high activity is
actually detrimental for brain function
and in autism it is often thought that
these balanced activity of the brain is
somehow abrogated so there is a altered
balance in the excitatory inhibitory
ratio in the neuronal circuit and this
is kind of true for many other diseases
like epilepsy where there is an
excitatory overdrive in autism it has
been reported that the garic input which
acts like a break on neuronal activity
in a circuit is shown to be uh low so
basically the excitatory overdrive is
due to the low uh inhibitory drive from
the gabar jic circuit there are many
other uh reason and cellular molecular
basis of autism development for example
these autism autism spectrum patients
show different mutations associated with
different category of genes and here is
a laundry list of the mutations now the
question is and what the scientists are
now thinking about that okay if a
patient has a mutation and have a
behavioral outcome how does these
mutation kind of relate to this kind of
Behavioral outcome what is going wrong
in the
brain so that is why understanding the
cellular and molecular correlates of
autism is really important and that is
why scientists want to categorize these
tools try to make transgenic models out
of it so let us try to understand how
scientists are trying to investigate
autism one of the way is to generate
transgenic Mouse models so these
transgenic Mouse models would be
subjected to several behavioral test
analysis and sometimes these Mouse model
also show very much autistic like
behaviors once those behavioral
paradigms are established then their
brain is used to understand at a protein
level or at a transcript level what has
changed so proteomic and transcriptomic
analysis could be performed from these
mutant
brains also functional assays like
functional Imaging calcium Imaging
electrophysiology these can be performed
to understand the circuit functionality
in these autism spectrum mutant
mice so with two Photon microscop it is
possible to image behaving animals in
real time so scientists leverage these
kind of tools to understand what what
goes wrong in the brain or in the brain
circuitry of these uh transgenic mice
harboring Au autism Associated
mutations and a lot of insight has come
into the picture especially with two
Photon microscopy deep tissue Imaging is
possible and that gives us a lot of
insight alongside two Photon microscopy
patch clamp recording can give us more
idea about the overall
uh abnormalities of the neuronal
circuitry parameters like capacitance
conductance firing frequency input
resistance firing pattern all of these
can be governed using
electrophysiological technique so using
this technique scientist found out that
there are specific mutations which are
like Shang 3 S Gap 1 all of these are
associated with the development of
synapse and the dritic spine so once
these proteins are mutated there are
alterations in terms of synapse
formation or synap aptic architecture
and that lead to the neurological
complications in the autism so obviously
autism is a neurodevelopmental disorder
all these abnormalities or differences
that a scientist can possibly observe or
anticipate in the later half of the life
come occurs during the time when the
brain was built or the brain was
developing but studying development of a
human brain is not at all a easy task
scientist use genetically modified Mouse
monkeys Etc to study this because often
these model partially recapitulate the
human brain development and human brain
development is happening inside the
mother's wound so basically studying
human brain development is literally
impossible due to ethical and Technical
constraints now in the recent years
scientists at Cambridge developed one
technique known as cerebral organoids
which kind of recapitulate cellular and
molecular basis of human brain
development now using these as a model
to study autism scientists found out
many many new insights about the autism
progression so autistic patient with
Shang 3 mutations were used in a study
where their ipss were converted into
cerebral organoids and once they
investigated the neurons that are
generated out of these cerebral
organoids they found the Soma size
neurite length branch number growth cone
area all of these parameters seems to be
altered in these autistic patient
derived
organoids that already gives us a clue
that how these mutations can possibly
affect the organoid development or the
brain development in
patients now autism doesn't have a cure
because sometimes the behavioral outcome
is so diverse that uh tailoring a
customized program is so diff difficult
but supportive programs are required to
help autistic children now it's also a
misn nor that these people are autistic
so it's always say it it is always term
that we are a neurotypical person who
behave normally or like others and these
child are actually neurod Divergent
people so neurod diverent people have
neurological structures and functions
that can lead to differences in the way
they perceive the world they are not
exactly abnormal they are not stupid
they are just different they perceive
the world differently let me examp let
me give you some example let's say these
pictures were shown to a child so
obviously a neurotypical child would
broadly say these are all the images of
a cat right but if this is basically
shown to a neurod Divergent person who
might have a autism related mutation he
or she would basically categorize them
as individual animal types so the point
is the same sort sort of like sensory
input is processed in a different way in
these children and studies are conducted
on these aspect so basically studies on
neurotypical person where their faces
facial expressions and eye movements are
tracked in that context people found out
when these neurotypical and neurod
Divergent population were asked to stare
at a particular image neurod Divergent
people tends to basically focus
on the center of the image so the top
image is mislabeled but the top image is
from a neurotypical person look this
neurotypical person is focusing on
different areas of the image especially
on the facial features but look at the
neurode Divergent person they focus on
exactly the center of the image instead
of the facial features or any other
features so nothing is wrong about both
these cases it's just that the
neurotypical person and neurod Divergent
person are perceiving the same thing in
a different manner
so that is all about autism I hope this
was informative if you like this video
give it a quick thumbs up don't forget
to like share and subscribe see you in
next
video